-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
President Biden
spoke today in Illinois
about his administration's
plan to support farmers.
Although, I feel like
he should be
asking about their plan
to support him.
"Do you guys got one of those
Charlotte's Web spiders
that could write
something nice about me?"
While speaking yesterday at
The White House
about the steps
he's taking to curb inflation,
President Biden
acknowledged that Democrats
"control all three branches
of the government."
Oh, so you are aware.
It's like hearing 6-year-old say
Genesis was better with
Peter Gabriel.
Definitely.
We just didn't know you knew.
Bill Gates announced yesterday
that he has tested positive for
a breakthrough case of
the coronavirus.
Gates says
he probably got the virus
because he forgot to
install McAfee.
That's right -- Bill Gates has
tested positive for coronavirus.
So for now, he's just going to
attend meetings on Zoom.
Oh, I mean, Microsoft Teams!
We all -- We love
Microsoft Teams, everybody.
A House intelligence
subcommittee is set, next week,
to hold the first open
Congressional hearing on UFOs.
Oh, come on.
How many times are you
going to make him testify?
According to newly released
audio from an interview
after the Capitol attack,
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham
praised President Biden
and said he's the
"best person to have in office."
And then today, he said,
"I'm gonna let that go
to voicemail."
Actor James Cromwell
superglued himself
to the counter of a Starbucks
in New York yesterday
to protest the chain charging
more for plant-based milks,
while over at Dunkin',
you kind of just stick to
the counter naturally.
Thank you very much.
Two unoccupied beach houses
in North Carolina
recently fell into the ocean,
or, as the Realtor put it,
360-degree ocean views.
A rat ran onto the field
during last night's
New York Mets game.
A staff member quickly caught it
and, out of habit,
tossed it to a kid in
the front row.
"Hi, baseball rat!
I got a baseball rat!"
And, finally, an alligator
was recently spotted
in the drive-through of
a fast-food restaurant
in North Carolina.
But this is annoying.
He had no idea what he wanted.
"Let's go!
Let's go!
You're holding up the line!"
And that was a monologue.
[ Laughs ]